on va maintenant distinguer le vrai du
faux avec notre chronique info intox
[Musique]
et un point toc c'est ce soir avec
Antoine fenaud bonsoir Antoine bonsoir
allez direction l'Ukraine ce soir avec
un bijou qui fait un polémique
absolument un bijou un homme et une
photo vous allez comprendre rapidement
la photo et les tweets que vous allez
apercevoir le voici il s'agit ici sur
cette photo de Valéry zaluzny en tout
cas c'est comme ça qu'on le présente il
s'agit du 1 de moins que du commandant
en chef des forces armées
ukrainiennes et le bracelet vous le
voyez le petit bijou dont je vous
parlais c'est ce qu'il a au poignet avec
un symbole qui apparemment retenu
l'intention de cette utilisateur de
Twitter qui voit et vous le voyez ici un
symbole nazi rien que moi qu'une croix
gammée cette utilisateur qui est quand
même assez réputé pour cette tendance
trop russe le dit ici il n'a rien à voir
vous le voyez juste le général en chef
des armées ukrainiennes qui a une vatica
donc le symbole nazi au poignet une
publication qui a également été partagée
ici vous le voyez par cette internaute
qui lui aussi est plutôt réputé pour ses
positions prorus et qui lui
également l'OTAN avec là encore une fois
un zoom vous le voyez sur le bracelet
que porte que porterait en tout cas
c'est officier ukrainien avec là encore
on le voit ici ce qui apparaît être une
croix gammée il faut savoir que
évidemment les médias russes d'État eux
se sont régalés on fait leur miel de
cette photo notamment le média russe RT
qui lui aussi a repris l'information
telle qu'elle avait la même photo que je
vous montrais juste à l'instant donc de
ce militaire ukrainien avec ce bracelet
à la main donc ash Rennes
Antoine oui absolument et c'est
peut-être ça qui est le plus surprenant
en tout cas ça a été relayé notamment
par un ancien candidat à la
présidentielle souvenez-vous François
Asselineau qui depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine se fait connaître pour
ses positions nationalistes et
anti-autant voire même des fois prorus
et mille releigh vous le voyez là encore
le même le même montage de cette office
de cette même photo donc de cet officier
ukrainien avec là encore le petit zoom
sur le bracelet que l'on aperçoit à son
poignet là aussi à une autre figure
médiatique souvenez-vous c'était l'un
des avocats des gilets jaunes Roanne
Branco lui aussi à partager cette même
photo avec il le dit cette belle
vatstica au poignet du commandant en
chef des forces ukrainiennes mais on
vous dit on vous le répète il n'y a pas
de problème voilà quoi cette photo
relayée donc côté francophone alors d'où
vient ce bracelet Antoine et bien ce
bracelet déjà pour le savoir il faut
d'abord savoir si la photo que je vous
ai montrée et authentique et il se
trouve qu'effectivement cette photo est
authentique elle a d'ailleurs été
diffusée par le commandant en chef des
forces ukrainiennes lui-même voire même
par le compte officiel de la défense de
l'Ukraine ça c'était la première
publication de cette photo vous le voyez
c'était en mars 2022 on voit donc la
même photo ici et la publication à
laquelle faisait référence donc les
accusations qu'on a vu juste avant et
bien c'était celle-ci là encore avec ce
elle a été publiée cette fois le 6
octobre dernier et donc là dans ce dans
ce tweet qui disait ici et bien ce
commandant en chef appelait donc à la
résistance de toutes les forces
ukrainiennes et il faut noter d'ailleurs
face à l'ampleur de la polémique que un
de ses officiers a d'ailleurs affirmé
que oui il portait bien ce bracelet que
l'on voit ici ça c'est un officier de
l'armée ukrainique il le dit sur
Facebook il dit c'était bien un
bracelet qui le portait mais il n'y a
pas de symbole nazi dessus et il me
relève même la marque de ce bracelet il
s'agit d'une marque crânienne qui
s'appelle paquebot et bien cette marque
logiquement nous nous l'avons retrouvé
ici à info un truc c'est effectivement
elle propose bien des bracelets de ce
type en vente vous le voyez ici j'en ai
sélectionné quelques-uns pour vous avec
différents
logos motifs qui font des références à
la mythologie nordique souvent voire
Viking en tout cas mais en tout cas on
n'a pas vu de svazzika ou de symboles
nazis parmi ceux-là certains internautes
se sont dit oui mais vous savez le
bracelet est modulable voici un autre
exemple vous pouvez mettre ce que vous
voulez dessus et notamment et le logo
qu'il pointait c'était celui-là il
s'agit d'une d'un euceltique c'est un
symbole Viking lui et ils disent bien
effectivement ce n'est pas un os que
l'on voit c'est un symbole nazi et bien
pourtant nous à un fantôme on va vous
montrer par A + B qui est bien c'est
bien un nœud celtique et que la
difficulté réside en fait dans la le
zoom de la vidéo et pour ça je vais vous
montrer regardez une photo de ce
bracelet et vous voyez lorsqu'on zoome
et qu'on floute la photo et bien
qu'est-ce que vous voyez la croix je
vais vous remettre la vidéo vous allez
la voir on voit donc le symbole ici de
du nœud celtique lorsqu'on compresse et
qu'on zoome la vidéo qu'est-ce qu'on
voit on voit ici une croix gammée vous
l'avez compris donc en fait il ne s'agit
absolument pas d'un symbole nazi mais
bien d'une photo qui a été défourrée
déformée et qui a pu prêter à confusion
certains s'en sont emparés notamment des
comptes pour russe je terminerai juste
pour vous dire que effectivement ces
accusations de néo-nazi et de nazis dans
l'armée Ukraine de son ne sont pas
récentes il faut dire que le bataillon
Azov de l'armée ukrainienne plaide pas
pour en ce sens effectivement il a été
fondé par des éléments d'extrême droite
mais nos confrères du monde nous le
rappelait c'est régiment lui représente
un peu moins de 2% des forces armées
ukrainiennes donc vous l'aurez compris
c'est une manœuvre des comptes prorus
ici une infox des comptes pro russe
destinés à décrédibiliser une fois plus
l'armée ukrainienne merci beaucoup
Antoine pour toutes ces explications
restez avec nous la suite de Paris
direct dans quelques instants